everyone i'm jennifer zabasanja with
bloomberg quick take in new york thanks
so much
for joining us by now you know that the
world woke up early friday morning to
the news that president trump
and first lady melania trump both tested
positive for covid19
and still at this point there's a lot of
unknowns which is why
we wanted to try and parse through all
of the information that we're getting on
this evolving story
and we asked bloomberg news white house
reporter jordan
fabian and bloomberg opinion columnist
jonathan bernstein
to be with us today for a few minutes
hey guys how's it going
good are you good to be here i know
both of you have not gotten that much
sleep so i really appreciate your time
uh today uh jordan i wanted to start
with you because you were actually at
the white house today can you walk us
through
sort of what the mood has been like
there and and what's the latest
information that you know
yeah yeah i mean i think this is the
news of the president tested positive
for coronavirus certainly came as a
shock to
a lot of staff at the white house and it
prompted some
changes at least uh slightly in behavior
there before
it wasn't typical for staff to wear
masks or really practice
social distancing around the west wing
but when i was there
earlier today the communication staff
was wearing a mask but i will point out
that when we had a gaggle sort of a
informal chat
with the white house chief of staff mark
meadows outside the west wing
earlier this morning he was not wearing
a mask and he actually got questions
about that because
hope hicks is someone who's very much in
the white house inner circle
and as we all know at this point a
negative test
does not mean that you are impo
incapable of spreading the virus so
um still a lot of questions about how
far this outbreak is spreading and how
the white house is handling it
yeah and so what was the reaction from
reporters there at the gaggle today with
mark meadows i mean how are you guys
feeling given
everything that's been going on i mean
anytime you're not
at home and not social distancing it's a
risk and that includes covering the
white house and especially today
uh now that we know there's a bunch of
positive cases so
your reporters are pressing mark meadows
not only why aren't you wearing a mask
while you're talking to us out here
but what additional steps is the white
house taking
to make sure that you know they can
trace
who has the virus and who they're
spreading it to and he said they're
going through the contact tracing
process
they're testing people who they think
were exposed but other than that it
doesn't sound like right now
they've put additional screenings in
place love to see if that holds
especially if that if the infection
spread further
yeah and you and your colleague jennifer
jacobs have been doing such great
reporting on this story
uh you actually broke the news on
thursday can you just tell us a little
bit about
how how you found out about this and and
what that was like thursday evening yeah
i mean you know
as you said a major credit to jennifer
jacobs uh my colleague
she was uh just a force on this story
and we were hearing from
uh sources uh yesterday evening
that there was a high profile a member
of the white house staff who's testing
positive
uh through the reporting process we're
able to nail down that it was in fact
hope hicks i think we
published that story somewhere around uh
you know 7 30
8 o'clock at night and uh and then the
world found out uh that one of the
president's uh inner circle aides
had been positive for the virus wow and
and jonathan i wanted to bring you into
um at what point did did you find out
and and what was sort of your reaction
given what we've heard from the
president
uh for the past few months yeah you know
i was uh
halfway through my morning writing uh
late at night
the newsletter for the morning on that
topic of well you know it's okay that
two and a half million people have
already voted because you know what what
exactly
i'm gonna do and you know then uh you
know i'm looking up at twitter and there
it is
so um you know with all respect
due respect to my colleagues who did
great work on this they shouldn't have
to be breaking stories like this
the hope hicks testing positive should
have been disclosed by the white house
right away you know and uh
it's important for them to establish
something they haven't done so far it
shouldn't be mark meadows giving
vague uh medical updates the real
doctors who are the relevant doctors
treating
president this situation should be
should have gone last night late last
night
really and given a full medical update
at the very least they should have done
it first thing this morning and it's
just
it's terrible they haven't done it yet
yeah and
you have a column actually out today
that's called honesty from the white
house is critical now
can you can you just tell us what is the
historical precedent
for what the white house is supposed to
disclose about
the president's health to the public
well there's a you know there's a long
history of going both ways you go back
to sort of
john f kennedy where he had serious
illnesses during his presidency that
were never disclosed
you had during the shooting of ronald
reagan
they didn't do a really good job now you
know suddenly to get
the president shot in the hospital when
you're not anticipating obviously
anything like that took some time to get
protocols and later during the reagan
administration
they did a better job when he had
surgery and since then
uh up through barack obama presidents
have done a pretty good job of
disclosing
what's going on and having the medical
people take the lead in disclosing
exactly what's going on and it's
important because
you know people don't even a res
administration which has built trust
with the american people which this one
of course hasn't um you know it helps to
have the medical people taking the lead
because they're the ones who can really
tell us things and they're the ones who
we are going to
pretty much trust so you think mark
meadows saying that
president trump isn't good spirits is
not not enough for the american people
it's not nearly enough and you know this
is exactly how
you wind up with rumors starting you
wind up with people starting to
believe you know crazy conspiracy
theories there's no reason to believe
those
but the truth is there's also not a
whole lot of reason to believe
what mark meadows is telling us he has
all kinds of political motivations and
he has
you know this white house has a history
of in general and on medical procedures
in particular
of not doing full disclosure so you know
it's important to get this out right
away it's important to establish trust
right away
and to do that with the medical people
who
people who you know citizens can
actually trust on these things
yeah and i think a lot of people
especially looking at the timeline of
events over the past few days still have
a lot of questions jordan uh you've been
with president trump and on air force
one what have you sort of seen
over the past few days
yeah that's right i was traveling with
the president in his entourage on
wednesday under
air force one that trip to minnesota
where
uh we later found out that hope hicks
was falling ill and was
placed in some sort of uh quarantine
aboard the plane on the flight
back uh you know on that fight we didn't
really have a sense of it
the pres the the air force one is sort
of divided into different cabins our
cabin's not
uh near where hope hicks would be so we
didn't have contact with her
but we did speak to mark meadows that
night uh we didn't give us any
indication that
that was happening we weren't sure if he
knew at that point what was happening
uh but uh certainly you know overall
the general approach to the virus has
been pretty cavalier on behalf of the
white house we were coming from
a campaign rally in duluth minnesota
where thousands of people
were packed closely together in cold
weather uh no masks
uh you know as i said no social
distancing uh you know
the white house staff not really wearing
masks at all
uh during at least the public portions
of that trip so
you know it's hard to tell where the
president got it where hope hicks got it
but uh they certainly haven't been
taking the necessary precautions what
are the health protocols in place
i mean for for being uh in the white
house um and on capitol hill for people
like yourself
yeah i mean because it's good for the
white house you know reporters
get tested every day we go in using one
of the
the rapid tests that gives you results
in 15 minutes staff
who are in close proximity to the
president also get tested every day
the president gets tested frequently
before this not sure exactly if that was
every single day uh but but frequently
we're told so
they have the testing uh you know
reporters at least wear
masks when we're on the air force one or
were in the white house to try to
protect ourselves and
use sand sanitizer and those sort of
things but the same
can't really be said for many of the
staff and the president of course who
rarely use masks yeah and we also heard
today
that senator mike lee also tested
positive
and we saw that picture of him with amy
coney barrett
um what do we know about sort of next
steps in
in her nomination and her confirmation
yeah right now we're being told that the
confirmation hearings that are set
to begin october 12th are not going to
be pushed back
but that could change if there are
additional senators who end up
contracting the virus i mean at a
certain point
it's going to just be impossible to hold
a hearing if you have say half the
judiciary committee unable to show up or
participate in some capacity so
uh this is a fast moving situation we'll
have to see how it plays out
over the next few days right now that's
on but it could be off
jonathan how do you see this affecting
the
election i mean it was already there was
already so much being crammed into the
next few weeks but
um what are you paying attention to over
the next few days
you know i don't like to guess how
people react to stuff like this how
general public so we're gonna wait for
the polls we're gonna see what kinds of
early polling comes out and of course
you know we're conflating
about six different major stories in the
polls that are coming out now so we have
the tax you know president not paying
taxes story we have the debate
we have subsequent to debate you know a
day or two
of um everybody talking about the
president refusing to
condemn uh right-wing violence and then
finally doing it last night and then you
know two hours later
um having having the virus so
you know and at the same time we've gone
over seven million cases we've gone over
200 000
uh americans dead so the virus by itself
is a major story and and you know all
the other
there's a major election story going on
about uh
republicans uh about the
president um falsely accusing
um the states of fraud and democrats of
fraud
so there's a whole lot of things
conflated so we're not going to really
know
what you know what the diagnosis
is doing to public opinion unless
there's some major spike one way or
another
um but that's i wouldn't want to guess
other than to say
that well you know we've had a year of
enormous stability in the polls
so it would at this point i think it's
fair to say it would be surprising if
there's a major spike one way or another
and do you think i mean we heard that
vice former vice president biden and his
wife
joe biden tested negative um for the
virus
is how do you anticipate this shaping
the next debate
um do you do you think i mean we had
issues of course with
with the first debate do you see it
going virtual potentially do you
see that being beneficial to either
candidate
well we're very early in this right so
we know that joe biden tested negative
but
uh if he was only exposed two days ago
it's possible that he could still wind
up having contracted it
we don't know very much at all about the
president's situation we don't know
if he'll be up to it in in two weeks we
don't know you know if he
will observe a two-week quarantine
period even if he's doing really well
um what i would say is that i i don't
understand why there was an audience
um during a pandemic uh in the in the
auditorium
i don't see why we would want to do that
going forward in the second
second debate it's supposed to be a town
hall debate um there's no reason to have
to
do even if you have the candidates in
the room there's no reason that the
uh voters need to be in the room with
that there's certainly no reason that
the various political celebrities and
all that have to be
in the room so i would hope at least
they restrict that going forward but
whether we'll have
any more debates you know we're going to
have to wait and see
and jordan have you been told anything
about this do you plan on
isolating yourself or um what have you
been pulled
yeah right now i think we're you know
we're trying to treat it as normal
try to get tested and just keep an eye
on things and but as far as the
president's travel goes i mean we just
heard
uh i think just before coming on air
here that his events are
are postponed or canceled for the time
being uh the vice president mike pence
will be going out on the road doing some
campaigning
for the president i think that vice
presidential debate that's scheduled for
next week uh i think it's october 7th uh
is is still a go uh but as far as the
other debates go
again we'll have to wait and see we'll
have to see you know how serious
the president's case is and whether he's
able to recover
and then prove that he's uh recovered by
the time those debates come around
and we don't do we anticipate him making
a public statement i mean we haven't
really heard from him
today at all that's right yeah that's a
great observation uh he hasn't he hasn't
tweeted it all
uh he hasn't uh sort of posted a video
or done anything
to sort of show how he's actually doing
and
you know to jonathan's point earlier you
know if you don't want to trust the
the words of you know is the president's
aides the best way
to see how the president's doing is to
hear from him uh
but right now there are no plans that we
know of that the president has to speak
or appear in public
uh the the white house has been sort of
dodgy about this all day
and they say they won't say if it's not
happening they won't say if it's
happening so uh stay tuned but as
of now nothing's scheduled wow okay so i
mean ever evolving situation and i
believe
the two of you are going to be working
all weekend and working your sources so
thank you so much for your time and
we're definitely going to check back in
with you at some point
on this story
thanks guys